nos piden primero encontrar el foco y la
directriz de la parábola moviendo el
punto naranja y la línea a sus
posiciones correctas aquí tengo este
punto que si muevo cambian las
coordenadas de él y también tengo esta
línea que también puedo mover y cambiar
la ecuación de la directriz
ahora bien recuerden que una parábola
consiste en todos los puntos que son
equidistantes del foco y la directriz es
decir si yo tomo cualquier punto en la
parábola y mido la distancia que hay de
ese punto al foco debe ser igual a la
distancia que hay de ese punto a la
directriz de hecho nos dicen que los dos
segmentos de línea verdes que ves cuando
apuntas a la parábola tienen siempre la
misma longitud entre sí usan los para
verificar que hayas encontrado el foco y
la directriz correctos eso es los dos
segmentos verdes que salen tienen
exactamente la misma longitud por lo
tanto para encontrar la directriz tengo
que y el foco también tengo que
encontrar un punto y una recta de tal
suerte que para cualquier punto de la
parábola el pie del segmento vertical
verde
siempre esté sobre esa línea entonces
bueno para encontrar el foco recuerden
que la parábola es simétrica respecto a
la línea formada por el foco y el
vértice así que por ejemplo esta podría
ser una opción pero noten que el pie del
segmento vertical verde si se está
moviendo verticalmente y no solo
horizontalmente así que lo voy a bajar
un poquito más vamos a ponerlo por aquí
hay muy bien porque aquí el pie del
segmento vertical verde no se mueve
verticalmente solo se desplaza
horizontalmente así que si yo traigo
esta línea que representa la directriz
aquí entonces el pie del segmento verde
siempre está sobre la directriz así que
apostaría a que el foco está en menos
140 y la directriz es la línea de igual
a menos 1 vamos a verificar esto y
obtener la ecuación voy a copiar estos
datos y pegarlos en un lugar donde pueda
trabajar
pero por acá
y bien vamos a calcular la ecuación de
la parábola
como les decía la parábola consiste en
los puntos que están del foco voy a
poner por aquí mi foco que va a tener
coordenadas menos un cuarto con más cero
no vaya a dibujar los ejes
y la directriz es la línea de igual a
menos 1 así que la directriz está más o
menos por ahí
esta es la directriz y tiene ecuación
igual a menos 1 entonces la parábola la
parábola como aquí lista del foco y de
la directriz se ve algo así
algo así yo creo
pero bueno lo importante es que
cualquier punto de la parábola digamos
aquí el punto de xm
si miro la distancia de este punto al
foco que sería esta distancia aquí
sin miedo esta distancia y la comparo
contra esta contra la distancia a la
directriz que noten que esto es un
ángulo recto ésta simplemente es una
vertical entonces estas dos distancias
deben ser iguales pero nosotros podemos
calcular fácilmente la distancia del
punto xy el foco eso sale directamente a
la fórmula para la distancia entre dos
puntos que es una consecuencia directa
del teorema de pitágoras así que
nosotros podemos calcular esta distancia
aquí y cuánto vale pues va a ser la raíz
cuadrada
partes cuadrada de x menos un cuarto al
cuadrado que sería x menos 14 x más un
cuarto al cuadrado
x más un cuarto al cuadrado
más el cambio en y al cuadrado pero el
cambio es simplemente de menos 0 así que
esto sería más al cuadrado y esto debe
ser igual a la distancia de este punto a
la directriz pero este punto de aquí
tiene coordenadas x coma menos 1
simplemente porque es la distancia
vertical así que esa instancia sería el
valor absoluto de el cambio que sería
menos -1 que sería ye más 1 la razón por
la que introduzco el valor absoluto es
para que esta instancia siempre sea
positiva de hecho otra cosa que podría
haber hecho es simplemente elevarlo al
cuadrado de más 1 al cuadrado y tomar la
raíz cuadrada así que tengo esta
ecuación lo que voy a hacer ahora es
elevar todo al cuadrado elevar esto al
cuadrado y voy a llevar esto al cuadrado
de modo que se cancelan las raíces y
obtengo x + 1 cuarto
al cuadrado más ya al cuadrado es igual
a de 1 al cuadrado más uno al cuadrado
y de una vez voy a ir expandiendo todo
esto de hecho este lado lo que tiene que
ver con x lo voy a dejar así porque
quiero algo que tenga esa forma y sólo
voy a expandir el lado derecho así que
obtendría x más un cuarto al cuadrado
más y al cuadrado es igual a y al
cuadrado más 2
más
bien ahora voy a también a restar
cuadrados de ambos lados
de ambos lados
llevar la ecuación a esta forma entonces
y el resto ya cuadrada de ambos lados
tengo x más un cuarto al cuadrado es
igual a esto llega al cuadrado se
cancela esto ya al cuadrado se cancela
es igual a dos más
ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir toda
esta ecuación entre 2 voy a dividir todo
entre 2 de modo que voy a obtener
un medio por x más un cuarto al cuadrado
es igual a ye más un medio lo único que
hice fue dividir todo entre dos pero
quiero la ecuación en esta forma quiero
que sea de la forma que menos algo es
igual a algo por x menos algo al
cuadrado así que para escribir la de ese
modo voy a reacomodar todos mis términos
y escribir esto como sigue
voy a intercambiar los lados de forma
que obtenga ye más un medio de más un
medio es igual a un medio por x más un
cuarto al cuadrado y ahora simplemente
voy a observar que ye más un medio es lo
mismo que ya menos menos un medio
y esto debe ser igual a un medio por x
más un cuarto es lo mismo que x menos un
cuarto
y todo esto al cuadrado y esto es
precisamente la forma de la ecuación que
queríamos esta es la forma de la
ecuación que nos pidieron así que mi
respuesta sería menos menos un medio y
eso
- menos un medio es igual a un medio de
x menos menos 14
así que voy a checar mi respuesta - un
medio un medio menos un cuarto
veamos entonces menos un medio
un medio y menos un cuarto verificamos y
estamos en lo correcto muy bien